i made a documentary years ago called it
might get loud yeah with jimmy page i
highly recommend that everybody watch
that documentary it's incredible
celebration of the guitar yeah it says
uh jamie page paige
jack white from my stripes the edge and
the edge from youtube
okay all right well now you have to tell
the story of that one because
how the heck did that all come together
because it's so fascinating such
different musicians all coming together
talking about their story talking about
how they approach the music and also
playing together a little bit in this
casual kind of setting well look i one
day i came downstairs and i the rolling
stone magazine is sitting there and it
was the 50th
was the 50 top guitarist of all time
their list
and then i had some other financial
report with video games and the top
video game at the time was guitar hero
right and then there was a third thing i
can't recall it but i just
and i said to myself what is it about
the guitar
that is so
central
to the rock and roll whatever you want
to call it like why is that the symbol
um
and i said to myself
i want to ask jimmy page why he picked
up the guitar because he's jimmy page
right
and so i called a friend of mine davis
guggenheim who had directed inconvenient
truth and i think still is but at the
time was the biggest documentary ever
and i called davis and i said look i
have this idea i want to make this
movie about the guitar
about different eras and styles and
whatever but i've never made a
documentary i don't know how to do that
so i was just looking for advice
and
thankfully because he's
one of the best
documentarians ever
davis is like you know what i can't get
this out of my head i'll direct it
which was amazing and we we wrote three
names down that represented
different eras and different styles
rarely do you get
you know you go three for three but it
was it was those three guys
and um
it was just it was just such a
incredible experience to sit there and
get to know
jimmy page you know i mean it was like
and he was
he was like gandalf man he was like
always
jimmy page yeah and um that was so cool
to see him
gandalf was
there's like a wisdom there's a calmness
to him compared to like the uh
restlessness of jack white like the um
i mean that that combination was just
fascinating it was one of the coolest
experiences ever
and one of the things there was a moment
where jimmy he was going through his his
guitar case
and he had the double neck from stairway
to heaven and he handed it to me and i
was like
i mean
it's it's like somebody handing you
excalibur or something yeah
amazing experience and the edge
one of the kindest human beings you'll
ever meet in your life
just an amazing person
um and i think you hit it right in the
head with jack because he's got that
that energy you know and constantly
pushing himself
but it's hard to believe it's been i
think 10 or 11 or maybe even 12 years
since it came out but
after watching it i realized like
how much it was needed and
i was almost surprised it didn't already
exist
it was like
yeah the guitar wasn't quite celebrated
like explicitly we almost didn't
acknowledge it
how important it was culturally it's
kind of amazing and the way it closed
from the song uh the way it was it's
called the weight yeah by the band yeah
yeah
that's because they didn't want to go
home yeah
we were we were shooting on a warner
brothers sound stage for three days when
we called it the summit where the three
of them came together yeah and the two
things i'll never forget is when
jimmy starts to play the riff from whole
lot of love yeah
edge and jack ceased to be
rock
you know rock gods or whatever and
had the same 15 year old kid feeling
that i did you could see in their face
and then at the end they're like hey can
we play we just want to we don't want to
go can we just play something
acoustically yeah
so we printed out the lyrics that's what
they wanted to play and they just sat
there and sat on those couches and just
such a good way to end yeah incredible
you